Pike welcome to Hannity and tonight
pouches big farewell goes off the rails
as Kareem Jean-Pierre loses control of
the White House Press briefing we're
going to show you the low lights that's
straight ahead tonight also house leader
Kevin McCarthy is now calling for the
DHS secretary mayorkas to resign after
refusing to secure the southern border
for two long years and later a story
that will shock and disgust you a new ad
campaign from a fashion brand featuring
kids holding teddy bears dressed in
bondage gear we have that full report
coming up but first we turn to the great
state of Georgia where the all-important
runoff is about two weeks away and Joe
Biden Kamala Harris they are missing in
action nowhere to be found and as of now
they will not be attending any rallies
or hitting the campaign Trail in any way
because apparently the Biden
Administration they are too toxic to
voters in Georgia but make no mistake
even if he doesn't step foot in Georgia
Joe Biden he's definitely on the battle
and any vote for Raphael Warnock is a
vote of confidence for Joe Biden a vote
to rubber stamp his radical agenda a
vote for more inflation high gas prices
violent crime wide open border you
people in Georgia you get to decide a
vote for one of the most radical
far-left politicians in the country and
on the other hand of Herschel Walker
wins the U.S Senate will be split 50 50.
in that scenario who knows you might
have so-called moderate from West
Virginia Joe manchin be put on the hot
seat and by the way they did after he
went along with the inflation increasing
act his poll numbers have plummeted uh
maybe he might be ready to switch
parties and be with people that if they
make a commitment to give his State a
pipeline don't pull it back after he
makes a vote that he didn't want to make
anyway Herschel Walker will join us
tonight along with Ted Cruz Lindsey
Graham at the site of a huge rally but
we begin tonight in the Washington swamp
and Sewer where it was a very big week
for Joe by moments ago he touched down
in Massachusetts where he will be
staying at a 20 million dollar compound
in the beautiful island of Nantucket for
the Biden family's annual Thanksgiving
celebration now one does have to wonder
whether the Biden money used to pay for
this lavish vacation is from the tens
and tens of millions of dollars the
Biden family Syndicate took in from
countries you know like our friends in
Russia and China Ukraine and of course
zero experienced Hunter and the big guy
they cashed in big time now before his
big trip to Nantucket Biden first hosted
a wedding at the White House one of his
grandchildren that he officially
recognizes not the grandchild that he
doesn't recognize now naturally the
Press Corps was shut out of that event
but Vogue magazine was given you know
exclusive access the only question I
have did the Biden family Syndicate that
the newlyweds get paid for the picks
anyway the next morning Joe enjoyed a
very special brunch celebrating his 80
30th birthday the oldest sitting
president in American history is now
even older on Monday a couple of big
turkeys and Joe Biden waddled out to the
White House lawn for the annual
Thanksgiving pardoning ceremony but as
it turns out those turkeys were not the
only ones granted clemency by the
administration because this week we now
learn that the White House asked a
federal judge to Grant Saudi Arabia's
Crown Prince MBS himself immunity in a
civil lawsuit over the death of
journalist Jamal khashoggi Biden of
course once referred to the Crown Prince
as his murderer and vowed to treat Saudi
Arabia like a pariah state but now he's
more than happy to offer federal U.S
immunity and when you look at that at
the exact same day the day after OPEC
plus led by Saudi Arabia all of a sudden
they're reconsidering an oil output
increase I'm sure just a mere
coincidence now Biden offers immunity
Saudi Arabia pumps more oil maybe it's a
quid and a pro and a quo with Joe again
anyway Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell
where are you guys uh that's right your
deep concerns surrounding so-called quid
pro quoes that was a giant fraud also
just like the left's climate change
hysteria now think about this in the
name of saving Mother Earth beautiful
mother earth right Biden shut down the
Keystone XL pipeline restricted oil and
gas drilling but he's blocking new
exploration permits but at the same time
he's offering immunity legal immunity to
a guy that he said was a murderer so the
Islamic Kingdom of Saudi Arabia he hopes
will drill more oil for his kind Deeds
just like his buddy Vladimir Putin got
his pipeline waiver after the bidens
made Millions from Russia while
simultaneously shutting down the
Keystone XL pipeline but bear in mind
the Saudis do not produce oil in a more
environmentally friendly way than we do
in the U.S and in order for the U.S to
use their Oil Well it has to be shipped
a massive gas powered cargo ships across
the ocean and if you think Democrats are
protecting the environment you're a fool
they are actually making it all worse
and by the way Joe is going to be paying
reparations up to what a billion dollars
to uh countries because of gas emissions
from the U.S everything he's doing is
driving up gas prices which is driving
up the cost of everything you buy in
every store you go to I hope you're
enjoying it now the green energy
movement is a sham but by the way so is
Biden's student loan handout now as the
president himself stated in September
their pandemic is over but clearly the
elections are not so in a latest scheme
to bribe young voters out in Georgia
Biden just extended the quote pause
through June of 2023. he knows this is
unconstitutional the courts are already
telling him that but is offering false
hope to people with student loan debt in
the hopes that they may make it out and
vote in Georgia for a Democrat don't
forget if you have a loan on a house or
a car or credit card debt or a small
business loan you will need to make all
of your payments on time but if you're a
35 year old with a hundred thousand
dollar master's degree in gender studies
from Harvard or whatever College you
went to you will now get a free pass
courtesy of hard-working Americans you
know contractors and and carpenters and
plumbers and electricians and nurses you
know they'll be paying for your college
and for the past two years Biden has
treated the federal government like a
slush fund for his supporters remember
there was the blue State bailout
multiple trillion dollar spending deals
of course the climate Bill disguised as
the inflation reduction act that
allocated hundreds of billions of
dollars to Joe's friends in the green
energy industry while doubling the size
of the IRS 87 000 new agents in order to
squeeze Americans into funding part of
the bill now needless to say most
America Americans are not happy with
Biden we have a new Emerson poll it has
him well underwater at just 39 percent
yet somehow the vice president is
polling even worse and that's why the
the vice president is polling worse
which is why the Biden Administration uh
is sending Kamala uh Harris farther and
farther away out of the public Spotlight
you probably didn't notice but she's
been in Asia for a while and here she is
once again talking about the
significance of something
something of significance take a look
this is my third trip to the
indo-pacific region as vice president
and really signifies the significance of
the relationship between the United
States and our allies and partners in
this region the discussions that we had
included in large part A discussion
about the significance of the climate
crisis and what we can do is the United
States to be a leader in that regard
now I know maybe it's far and distant
for many of you but on December the 6th
coming up soon in Georgia you can choose
to reward Kamala Harris and Joe Biden
with a 51st Senator or you can choose to
hold them accountable with someone who's
not going to be a rubber stamp for their
radical agenda the choice is for you and
the people of Georgia and a lot is at
stake hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else